is trusted though by 69 percent of
republicans spencer kimball of emerson
college conducted the poll for us
let's also look at the issues we asked
the the people who were polled about
issues that matter to them as they're
heading in to vote in the upcoming
primary
crime
not very high the economy
very very high and coming in in the top
spot
does that translate as well into what
you're seeing across the country as we
head into the primary season
yeah it's the economy is the number one
issue
across the board in every state now
remember these are republican primary
voters and so with amongst republicans
the economy usually ranks a little bit
higher than let's say health care and so
these numbers are generally in the
trends of what we're seeing the issue of
crime and immigration uh they're
percolating but they're not the number
one issue the pocketbook issues are the
number one issues for these voters then
we're going to get into the issue of
immigration and crime as they percolate
up at around 30 percent combined
which makes it interesting because the
two top candidates that the poll seems
to show are ahead sheriff lombardo
former state attorney general adam
laxalt obviously have history in law
enforcement does that just come down
from what you've looked at here to to
name recognition
yeah i would say the name recognition
and the trump endorsement are what
carrying the day for those two
candidates as you mentioned the state
gop really endorsed two other candidates
last week and neither one is is in
really competitive position at this
point so
uh as as the campaigns really now are
going to come into a full motion about a
month out five weeks out from election
day i expect to see a lot more
advertising and if you're going to see a
move on with one of these candidates
this is going to be the time and as you
bring it up the issue is going to be the
economy so as we look at what what these
candidates talk about they're going to
have to make the case that they're
stronger than either lombardo or laxalt
and governor of the senate race when it
comes down to the economy
we're back obviously a lot david to
digest from these poll results what
stood out most to you so i think the big
takeaway here is of obviously as you
just heard the economy clearly number
one issue here for voters this cycle we
talk about it a lot with jobs inflation
that kind of stuff so they will be
voting of course with their pocketbooks
even in the primary in a couple weeks
and the question is if this is going to
guide where the commercials go the ads
go which you see on tv from these
candidates maybe they might focus on the
economy more moving forward david good
to see you once again appreciate it if
you want to take a closer look at the
poll results we have them right now at
eightnewsnow.com
we also focus on a couple of other
issues with regards to the republican
primary you might be interested in that
just check on the politics tab on eight
newsnow dot com
the nevada state republican party threw
a bit of a wrench into those command
commanding leads by adam laxalt and joe
lombardo as we mentioned earlier the gop
endorsed joey gilbert for governor and
sam brown for senate instead of the
front runners the perceived frontrunners
it happened during a party meeting last
weekend nevada's democratic party isn't
endorsing candidates it isn't running
the campaigns of sitting nevada
democrats either that's being run by a
group called nevada democratic victory
nationally democrats are preparing to
help governor steve sisilak hold on to
his seat the democratic governors
association is placing a massive 10
million dollar ad buy here a separate
democrat national organization is
placing an ad buy to back democrats in
the state assembly and state senate
races
republican national committee chair ron
mcdaniel was in las vegas this week to
open a new office it's inside the
chinatown plaza it's for outreach into
our asian american community asian
americans are the fastest growing
demographic in nevada and in the u.s
currently 11 percent of the electorate
this is a way for our party to introduce
ourselves to communities that have not
always been republican
share our values but also hear back ways
that we can serve better and represent
those communities better
so we're thrilled to be here in las
vegas and we're seeing really big gains
especially with the filipino community
here you have a lot of pacific islanders
here it's the 9th island
so we're excited to be here in nevada
republicans say their emphasis on faith
family and personal reliance reflects
the values of the asian-american
community
nevada democrats have sent an official
bid to host the nation's first
presidential primary in 2024. new rules
for which state gets to go first they're
very favorable for the silver state it
focuses on diversity and battleground
status nevada's also already switched as
you know from a to a primary from a
caucus the state party and the cutout
group we mentioned earlier in the
program they're running campaigns
working on this in unison trying to get
nevada the first democratic primary
other political news this week las vegas
city council member michelle fiore was
injured in a car crash her campaign says
she suffered a broken orbital bone and
head trauma in the collision this was
monday night near tanea and centennial
parkway police say both drivers involved
were responsible fiori's been on the
city council since 2018 she is a
republican candidate for the state
treasurer's office
next on politics now abortion in nevada
the laws in our state and the impact of
a potential supreme court rejection of
roe v wade
welcome back to politics now
stop
trying to tell women what to do with our
bodies
this week pro-choice protesters held a
quick rally in front of the downtown las
vegas federal courthouse
the protest came after politico released
what it says is a draft copy of supreme
court justices the majority discussing
an abortion case they have on the docket
now there is a lot to get into here with
this issue first it's important to know
nevada is one of 16 states with the
right to an abortion in state law it's
codified in state law here in nevada it
is legal up to 24 weeks to get an
abortion and afterwards if the mother's
health is threatened overturning
nevada's law would require a vote by the
people during an election the most
recent polling does show more than 60
percent of nevadans support our abortion
law christian kositas lays out the swift
reaction to the story here in the silver
state as long as i'm governor of the
state of nevada i will do everything in
my power to protect women's right to
choose
everything we've heard from nevada
lawmakers on both sides of the political
spectrum democratic senator jackie rosen
tweeting these unprecedented and
dangerous attacks on reproductive rights
can't go unanswered it's time to codify
roe into law and from republican
candidate for senate adam laxalt if the
leaked draft reflects the supreme
court's ultimate decision it would
constitute a historic victory for the
sanctity of life i'm pretty confident
that it will it will it would happen
possibly in june and and this is also
showing how elections have uh
consequences uh donald trump when he was
president nominated three of the supreme
judge justices jesus marcus is a nevada
republican analyst and says those
responsible for the leak should be held
responsible in the history of the court
we had never had
any leak like this and we had had very
controversial decisions if the decision
was overturned our state protection
enacted in 1990 would still be applied
those who really need it those who are
already marginalized and have difficulty
accessing care so these are our black
women are indigenous people of color
young people transgender and non-binary
people as well dr nikka viscara says she
is not surprised after seeing how
abortion rights have been under attack
for years this would be
really terrible for overall health
because we know that abortion
is a safe
is extremely safe as an option for
pregnancy christian casares 8 news now
on the national level the focus is on
what a supreme court decision will
actually say and what that will mean as
far as court precedent going forward i
spoke with washington d.c correspondent
alex limon
democratic lawmakers talked a lot about
protecting abortion access so alex what
moves can they make if the supreme court
does end up striking down row
hey john well democrats have talked a
lot a lot this week about protecting
legal safe access to abortions
nationwide because they say that
not doing that you know if roe is struck
down it isn't necessarily going to lead
to fewer abortions it's just going to
lead to more dangerous abortions
happening instead that would put mothers
lives at risk and so they have been
fired up
talking about wanting to protect you
know federal legal access to abortion
but the reality is that they have
very few options at least right now to
accomplish that you know in congress
there is the women's health protection
act um a bill that's very popular among
democrats that would essentially codify
the protections that we have seen under
roe
the issue is that democrats just don't
have the votes to pass that in the u.s
senate they don't have the 60 votes they
would need to overcome a filibuster and
so there has been some talk among
democrats about an effort to maybe try
to get rid of the filibuster maybe just
get rid of it for this specific
purpose but already we've heard from
democratic senators like arizona senator
kirsten cinema who says she would not be
supportive of that idea so they also
don't have the votes for that so wipa
doesn't seem like a realistic bill that
can be passed right now and even beyond
uh
roe versus
roe v wade and the discussion of the
supreme court democrats say if federal
abortion rights are struck down other
rights it could be next specifically
what are they concerned about
yeah and president biden has talked
about that concern repeatedly he said
you know could state states like florida
for example decide that they don't want
same-sex marriage to be legal in their
states
the reason that they are concerned about
other rights you know being struck down
by the courts next is because
um again this opinion that was leaked
from the supreme court isn't the final
opinion but if it does
if it is issued as that draft was
released then
some of the reasoning for why roe would
be struck down is because it isn't a
specific right access to abortionism a
specific right that's outlined in the
constitution and therefore the supreme
court and republicans say that it should
be left up to the states well if that's
the reasoning that's used then you can
say the very same thing about same-sex
marriage it is not a right that is
specifically outlined in the
constitution it's also not a right that
congress has passed a specific law to
protect that right uh same thing for
access to contraception or access to uh
abortion pills also known as plan b or
there's also plan c pills
there's a whole long list of rights that
americans have because of court
decisions not because they're in the
constitution specifically or because
congress has passed laws too and so if
that's the reasoning that's used then it
can be used for a whole long list of
other things as well
that was alex limon from washington d.c
a fee hike for small businesses next on
politics now why the health district
wants businesses to pay more and why
many are balking at the request plus the
new head of the fbi here in las vegas
talks about his role in his agency's
role in election security
from all my heart
you're watching politics now
the fbi says more children are being
targeted for sexual images and then
being tricked into scheme to try and get
money it's called sex extortion and it
is very much a crime in particular the
fbi is seeing more young boys being
targeted criminals posing as young girls
to trick them into sending sexual images
through social media than trying to
extort money the fbi is urging parents
talk with your children about this and
know what they're doing online
don't assume you know my kid is a good
you know student or they're a scholar
athlete
or you know because they go to church or
for whatever other reason this would
never happen to them it really runs the
spectrum of kids that are targeted
that's spencer evans the new special
agent in charge of the local fbi office
in las vegas
the 8 news now i-team's vanessa murphy
spoke with him for a one-on-one
interview
special agent in charge spencer l evans
starting here at the fbi office in
southern nevada during an especially
busy time the nfl draft on the las vegas
strip just wrapped up crime is up across
the country and it's an election year
the fbi will be working with a variety
of partners both on the law enforcement
side and on the election commission side
both at the state and federal levels
back at fbi headquarters and in every
field office to make sure that elections
are fair and open and safe
there's specific and very prescriptive
ways that we go about doing that to make
sure that there's no undue influence
being brought to bear by the fbi or its
partners on any sort of influence or any
sort of
election but
those efforts will start to ramp up
they've already been well in the works
for the last several months and shifting
to a pandemic related issue he says the
fbi is investigating kovid 19 relief
dollars this is something the i-team has
reported on about some individuals
receiving that money who shouldn't have
reporting in las vegas vanessa murphy
live local now
businesses in southern nevada are about
to see a fee hike this week the southern
nevada health district approved a 27
percent increase to its environmental
health fee the health district says it's
to keep up with inflation christian
cousins looks at the issue that affects
every business here
they're trying to do a game of catch-up
on their own
and we're paying the consequences
another expense angelica nielsen says to
add to their growing list of costs for
this 15-year-old business off saharan
decatur
the pastry palace still recovering from
the pandemic now it's just one of many
businesses in the valley getting hit
with the new bill hike by the southern
nevada health district it makes a
difference
our customers complain to us all the
time why things
like why our cakes are more expensive
it's like well everything that we have
to pay for is also going up this week
the southern nevada health district
approved a 27 percent hike to its
environmental health fee which is
expected to generate about 25 million
dollars in 2023 with an annual increase
up to three percent after here's a kind
of a breakdown just general fast food
all the permits that they may require
you know they'll go up 106 dollars so
you know you think about the years 365
days that's way less than a dollar a day
they say the fee helps pay for things
like inspections food operations and
compliance solid waste and consumer
health the fee revenue according to the
health district's presentation no longer
covering their expenses it's about 300
300 and something
so meaning it's going to go up
around 100 and something dollars as
nielsen and her team continue to recover
from the pandemic she understands the
reason behind the hike it's only the
timing that's rough even if it increases
like whatever you can complain about it
but you still have to sign your check
christian casarez 8 news now
health district officials say this fee
increase will help with public safety
and
588 4800
in what to watch the first debate of the
republican senate primary adam laxalt
and sam brown will have their debate
next week on the cw station up in reno
so far laxalt has only agreed to that
debate and clark county sent out sample
ballots for the primary election this
week early voting starts on may 28th the
county expects people will receive their
mail-in ballots the week leading up to
early voting that'll do it for us here
in politics now we'll see you next week
take care
[Music]